we just published an article it's
stronger by science on the show when we
publish a new article we often have a
little discussion about it so greg why
don't you tell us about the new article
yeah sure so the the title of this
article is the most commonly neglected
movements and muscles parentheses and
exercises to address weak links close
parentheses this is a guest article by
cameron gill who has written
uh two or three other really good guest
articles for stronger by science before
a big fan of his content
and um yeah so so this one
uh i i found very interesting i think
this is my personal favorite of his
articles he's written for the site so
far
um and so you know it's basically like a
survey of
what muscles are trained quite well like
what muscles or muscle groups are
trained quite well by the big exercises
people commonly do in the gym so
pressing exercises upper body pulling
exercises uh you know hip hinge style
lower body exercises squat style lower
body exercises and then what muscles are
neglected by by those movements uh which
you know might benefit from a little
love and so uh he identified uh three
kind of broad categories of muscles that
tend to be pretty neglected by those big
exercises that most people focus on
and that would be scapular protract
muscles that that participate in
scapular protraction so you know most
things were retracting our scapula so
scapular protractors primarily the the
pec minor and the serratus anterior
might be getting neglected the hip
flexor group as a whole might be getting
neglected so unless you're doing a bunch
of leg raises maybe
you know maybe you're doing leg raises
for the purpose of ab training but
you're also
primarily training your hip your hip
flexors if you're not doing any of that
your your hip flexors probably aren't
getting enough love and also your hip ad
abductor group
and so i i found this article really
interesting because one of the things
cameron did is is basically tried to
quantify um
how
how much muscle mass are we neglecting
by not training these muscles and so you
know coming right out of the gate your
scapular protractors uh
on the whole take up
more total muscle volume than your lats
do and that's primarily from your
serratus anterior which i was surprised
to learn is a very large muscle group i
did not know your serratus anterior was
that large but like in untrained folks
their serratus anterior is like 90
percent the total muscle volume of their
lats and you know where we we tend to
not train the serratus that hard um
similar with the uh the hip flexors uh
overall the the total volume of the hip
flexors group is about 12 percent
greater than that of the gluteus maximus
which i think is the largest muscle in
the body um so you know if you're not
training your hip flexors that is a lot
of muscle mass that's that's being
neglected um so yeah it makes the case
for why you should probably want to
train those muscles how how much of your
total muscle mass you're neglecting if
you aren't and then uh you know a bunch
of exercises that you can use to target
those muscles um so yeah it's it's a
really good article you should check it
out
one question that's already come up
after sharing this
is uh someone basically asked like
you know if i'm if i care mostly about
my physique like why should i care about
this like what what visual difference
will it make if i'm training my scapular
protractors if i'm training my hip
flexors etc
uh and i think that in i think that for
the most part
you're dealing with with deep muscles
so i think it's helpful to think of it
the same way you might think of like
brachialis training so
you know you don't really see your
brachialis if it gets bigger you're not
going to look at someone and be like
dude you have sick brachialis
development but since it lies deep to
the bicep when your brachialis gets
thicker it pushes your bicep further
from your humerus and so you know the
the top of your bicep peak is then
further from
the rest of your arm and so your your
whole arm just looks bigger and more
developed and i think that's the case
for for most of these muscles like um
you know if if your hip flexors get
bigger most of them are on the anterior
portion of your thigh they tend to
they they're they're either deep to or
in the same general area as your quads
so you know better developed hip flexors
will probably just you know someone who
doesn't know anatomy super well if you
have really developed hip flexors
they'll probably be like dude you have
huge quads uh or like your pec minor it
lies deep to your pecs kind of on the
upper and outer part
of your chest so you know it'll just
look like slightly better upper chest
development
if you if you develop your pec minor so
i think those are are the sorts of
visual differences you can anticipate um
but yeah there's there's a
lot of muscle in your body that you
probably aren't training uh quite as
hard as the rest of your muscle so uh
you know might might make sense to uh to
to show those muscle groups a bit of
love